well I told you that a lot of people
looked and sounded bored during Donald
Trump's big 2024 announcement it turns
out that it wasn't just my perception
people were trying to leave the room at
Mar-A-Lago last night and Mar-A-Lago
staff blocked people from leaving the
room understand that the Trump
announcement was so boring people were
trying to get out and they were forced
to stay in the room here is ABC's
Jonathan Carl
folks this this is beyond parody it is
stunning that this is the world we now
live in listen to this incredibly low
energy I actually saw people trying to
leave
um and people leaving early even by the
way Trump is speaking right now or he
was not he's still speaking now uh and
and then they I think perhaps a little
concerned that that the hallway the hall
would empty out too much they actually
started preventing people from leaving
so now they're no longer allowing
what an electric atmosphere at
Mar-A-Lago where it's quiet enough for a
reporter to do a stand-up while the
speech is still going on I mean think of
that that that in and of itself is
amazing and increasingly of course the
question is has Trump fizzled out the
polling is not looking good DeSantis is
leading Trump in just about every poll
and Trump's not even I'm sorry DeSantis
hasn't even announced that he's running
for anything yet so the question of
whether Trump fizzled out is one
question
the speech really was very low energy
and at one point the camera panned to
Trump's family and they were all just
kind of standing there awkwardly it
wasn't even really clear they were that
into it and there were some reports that
not everybody in Trump's family wanted
him to do this Ivanka Trump as far as
was reported wasn't even at the speech
and we actually have video here
um I'll play this you can see a crowd
Milling from screen right to screen left
and they're just quite literally blocked
there's a bunch of staffers in the lower
left
preventing anybody from getting out they
the the entire thing was going to empty
out and people were blocked security or
whatever these people are not letting
them leave forget about freedom of
speech they don't even have freedom of
movement at Mar-A-Lago
um so that was quite quite remarkable
here's another moment of just how bored
people were that this was while Trump
was speaking and you see many empty
seats and just absolutely no energy here
they've devalued their currency whether
it was the pound or whether it was the
one or the Yen yeah and I used to fight
like cats and dogs with the leaders of
other countries like a dog
um video at one point also caught Roger
Stone this is pretty funny Stone was
there and I can't think of anyone
looking more bored about all of this
than Roger Stone he looks like he's
wondering where the exits are or maybe
the bar
and they let it go back up instead of
putting America last as the Biden
Administration has done very very openly
and bravely my God what it really was
like um like Hotel California you can
check out anytime you want but you can
never leave and much of the crowd
mentally checked out but quite literally
not allowed to leave just one more clip
here just to give you the flavor of what
was going on one guy doing YMCA okay
check if you're watching look at the
middle of the room
oh my God
he notices no one else is doing it and
then he stops so lower energy hard to
imagine Trump didn't seem that into it
his family certainly didn't seem that
into it the crowd didn't seem very much
into it and one of the most interesting
aspects of this was even Fox News didn't
seem that into it and I want to talk
about that next
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below